hello welcome back to hey [ __ ] podcast
we want to really quickly start off this
episode by saying it's brought to you by
Buffy the comforter not the Vampire
Slayer their latest product the breeze
is made entirely from a hundred percent
eucalyptus fiber to keep you cool and
comfortable all night long fresh so if
you get hot during the night this will
keep you cool and for $20 off your first
Buffy comforter visit Buffy CO and enter
the promo code b-tch through it be when
he tell us off
ch hello by the blanket because I'm
actually want the blanket
I want it well you know what you
couldn't get the blanket and amusing the
code you can return to free of charge
her so they have like a trial period
okay I don't think you should returning
that for that back to another episode of
hey [ __ ] podcast we got Gina I'm Nikki
we got bows and we got Tiff's hi hi hi
[ __ ] I bet just good afternoon [ __ ]
and today I think we're talking about
every dudes wet dream which is like
dicks all dicks all day long girls are
so you know like a guy's question and
it's funny because I feel like it's a
topic people touch on all the time but
there's still no definitive answer and
you know like um for women it's like
should I care about dick size you know
there's a lot of like questions like is
my boyfriend's dick small like I didn't
know that like my I had dated a lot of
big dick dudes and I didn't know they
had big dicks
be until I dated a small dick dude and I
was like oh [ __ ]
the whole time I just thought that was
an average size and turns out it turns
out they had big dicks and the guy I was
dating had an average-sized it'll go to
you I mean I'll measure it like 8 8 9
inches
damn girl Wow science queen I didn't
know it love I been I think it's a
personality you know like I'm trying to
do a certain personalities I have and it
just happens to be bad again edgy energy
yeah yeah but that's true like two of my
most favorite guys of everyday to my
life of the greatest personalities ever
had huge dongs
okay so you're like starting this off
baby like confident yeah gross dicks you
know what I'm going to
confidence pill it's crosed a pump in a
pill and then I'll selling it one of
those like sketchy sex mark maybe that's
what they're selling in those dick
enlargement hospitals powdered
computation the pill just has a little
piece of paper it's my phone number and
I called him I just compliment them
you're successful you're worth it I
thought that this was gonna lay clean
it's like you know and even if you have
a small dick or like like for girl it's
like so your boyfriend has a small dick
what's next but like immediately they
started off and they're way too crazy
that scares me yeah nine inches I'm
running away talk about that so like is
there is there a too big or too small
because I think that's number one
question sure what is too big and what
is too small so this is really shitty so
um there was a guy that I lost my
virginity to so I told you guys about
that let a few episodes ago and that was
like an average size whatever and plus
it hurt because it was my first time
well the second time like years later
when I had sex
later on I think well I mean like the
guy that we we know about oh yeah like
earlier in my damn you know about this
guy
yeah earlier in my dating life I dated a
guy and he was half dutch half Chinese
and he was like the most unsuspecting
tall lanky looking asian dude yo like
that wasn't a penis it wasn't a dick
that was a [ __ ] dong dude like like
what he worked it out I was like oh like
the girls know this is actually the
first dick pic I think we ever said I
said well we ever sent in a group chat
because I was like yo you guys gotta see
this [ __ ] and then Ike um it's funny
he's a good friend of mine like yo you
got any pics and your phone he's like
yeah out of it she didn't only send a
photo she sent a video yeah yeah we like
just to put it in perspective he can
suck his own bellybutton if you wanted
to yeah but then I was like can he
understand but it honestly though it was
too big it does hurt like I'm not about
having all up in my cervix and [ __ ] so
if there is such thing as something
that's too big I loved our sex but
there were times I was like yeah chill
and then like the whole question about
anal was just no that wasn't absolute no
at all because like I do not want
pooping just like justjust dryer always
yeah mhm and is there a too small there
is a too small uh there there's a guy
that I dated I told you guys about that
uh when I held his dick in my fist
it did not pop out do you know has a
pretty tiny fist and I yeah yeah eighty
physica my is not completely
disseminates but yeah like I couldn't I
couldn't feel anything and it was really
it was really disappointing so there is
the I have a sweet spot and that's like
around like six or seven inches okay
yeah pretty that's average like six is
yeah I've never measured like the
everybody measures the same rates from
the [ __ ] to the t-shirt no that's so
funny because I did have sex with a guy
once that I feel like he could be
classified technically as having a micro
penis like it was so really like it was
like well it was like an enlarged
clitoris yeah it was really small I feel
like it might have been like my pinky
size hardy hard yeah and not that much
thicker like it was really it was a baby
thing really I mean and um yeah it
didn't last long was that guy but it was
really funny though because he really
needed to inflate his ego and he kept
telling me like when we would have sex I
can't doesn't that feel amazing like
tell me how big I am blah blah blah and
I'm looking at him like yeah
we would be better if he just owned it
it was like honestly it was like this
was when I was a teenager so I didn't
really have a lot of experience but I
didn't really feel much with him and if
I think he just didn't know how to use
it like mmm I don't know
it is pretty damn small but I feel like
maybe he could have used his hands again
let's go back to the hands like you get
pleasured me in other ways but he just
he had it in his head he had such a
big-ass dick that that's the only thing
that needs to satisfy me for me is like
if they grind on near the clitoris part
like it doesn't matter it really the big
size cuz yeah like I could probably come
just from dry humping yeah yeah yeah
yeah I probably could yeah I've been
with someone that has like a smaller
penis before but the thing is he knew
how to work the [ __ ] out of that thing
that that thing was amazing so it's not
all about size but I guess when it comes
to like micro penis and you don't really
have much to work what you have hands in
your mouth like this man refuse to go
down there like oh it was nothing with
yeah I think I think men who are who
don't eat [ __ ] are them set their
[ __ ] yeah they are you're less of a
man and I will never I will never
respect that yeah dj khaled I just don't
like if they're not gonna go down then
I'm gonna go down so you'll just never
ever get your dick sucked yeah have you
guys ever met a guy who refuses to kiss
you after he comes in your mouth I have
yet so I knew a guy we didn't really I
don't think we ever had sex but we kind
of like dated a little bit in high
school again he was so immature that he
was like have you ever sucked dick
before and I'm like I thought he was
like this is like maybe if I said yes I
he'll get turned on cuz I don't think I
had before that but I was just like yeah
like you want me to suck your dick or
some [ __ ] and then he immediately was
like never I don't even want to kiss you
like that's disgusting I can't believe
you've done that and all that gay
clothes like what what the [ __ ] yeah I
think it's like yeah I don't want to
know that you've ever had someone else's
Dickie oh it's my god like he kept going
in on it he was like okay never mind of
no interesting he's like I don't ever
what a girl is that guy ever gonna date
this right
there's plenty of women that won't that
won't suck a dick I don't suck your dick
unless weird like dating yeah I feel
like if you're look man I've met a guy
once before who was like I don't wanna I
don't kiss girls
like I'm not gonna kiss you after I [ __ ]
on your mother like stop being a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] make out with me I told you
guys once before right like oh yeah I
found mice I'm pretty sure I found my
soul mate once because I believe in more
than one soul mate but I'm pretty sure
if I said on an episode of one of our
shows that if a dude came on me licked
it off and made out with me
I'm marrying him oh my god [ __ ]
Miriam and it actually had licked it off
yeah it made out with me dude it
happened once and then after sex I
looked at him like just like just
[ __ ] rosy tinted glasses I was like
look it's not a matter of wanting you
now it's a matter of [ __ ] needing you
know and I love that man I loved him
what happened to him
oh he's ahe's were still friends okay
okay yeah but you ever had a grower a
grower so mostly people outdated they
were showers right so like I which sees
which get like it's the same basically
the same length soft as it is hard it
just like goes up and down but then I
dated a grower which I thought like oh
wow this is my first like baby penis
right yeah it's like not very no it just
grew enormous yeah yeah and it was it
was like it was like when you those
little shrinky towels that you put in
water so for me that would be like if I
got a small husky but it
you know like I don't dude for me I'm
like y'all know I like how in Google
flights you can choose like well here's
my day but I'm flexible like this day
yeah my date is the sixth and I'm
flexible one day out behind front like
that's where I'm at but I think that
it's not for you know and a lot of
people say this it's not all about the
Wiener side yeah for me I think you need
to diversify your bonds there are a lot
of other you know sectional investment
hearts of men we're talking about the
ball sack we're talking about the butt
cheeks oh you like big balls and foul
balls what do you like oh just let go
footballs aren't tight collarbones
I love collarbones knees you're know
last rule collarbones there's something
about it that's very like masculine like
a guy's like upper chest area here
sometimes it's like really defined and
I'm like I want you to knock me out with
your [ __ ] car never notice on the
man's collar bone yeah yeah collarbone
is whole like above the breast area but
like but like they have to be kind of
built for that to have that right I mean
sometimes it's like some guys are like
they don't even work out but naturally I
don't know if it's the testosterone it's
just flowing or something but like they
got they've got like a really nice like
chest and like up area so like there's a
lot of like there's a lot of different
things that make me happy yeah yeah I
know everyone has their own preferences
because for me it's definitely the
jawline like that should makes me weak
yeah so but you're okay let's say a dude
had like the prettiest clavicle you've
ever seen but then he had like a tiny
tiny or too big of a day is it one day
out for my flight a week girl wait
what's your flight six inches so it's
just six weeks and then we can go down
yeah but I don't want to go out of eight
I do not want to go out unless you're
scared out a little bit
that's awesome on the eighth you don't
know you know the seventh can be an
eighth Evan can be the hate on like a
dude that has measured his dick laughs
times it's like you can be an eighth
yeah it's a [ __ ] eighth of big
wieners a deal-breaker for me it's scary
dude no series for you as is eight seven
and a half seven and a half is too big
yeah that's like that's like you're
trying to [ __ ] kill me I think 10 is
too big Oh No thank you oh my god I
never even touched that I'd never
touched it either I've seen pictures and
I'm like nope too big I know but I think
Nikki's the type to climb a bedpost
three times to lose my virginity because
like I wouldn't go in oh you mean that I
wouldn't like to be stretched
she's like she's like you know in high
school I was really tight and you know
now I'm incredibly tight sometimes I
can't even I can't even walk
I'm just so tight but I love a tenant
like the pain mixed with like you know
like when girls like anal like they've
never done I like I can't really it I
know I've tried it one time I'm like
immediately out get it out get it up eat
it
but like girls are like if you just
relax a little bit like you stopped
noticing the pain that it becomes more
pleasurable like the but they have to
work through that pain for it to find
the pleasure I think it's s me with my
normal whole you have to relax you get a
real I don't want to do it relaxed this
finger I say I've never done it I just
wanna say relax you as the anal
ambassador I want to say that I have
done it but this only happens like I
only I only take it up the butt on like
special days or like days we're both
like drunk and when I'm drunk I like do
you prep no not really like I know how
my body or the whole like if I know like
okay you know like I clean up like
whatever but when it's like when I'm
like drunk I want like nasty sex you
know like [ __ ] clean me whatever but
what about Chinese dude huh Chinese dude
with him that's what I'm saying I
married that they're never gonna be it's
not gonna happen yeah like I kind of
size it up for his like okay you know
what that wouldn't hurt so we're good
right so it's kind of almost like I mean
so like I let you in my ass but if I
don't let you take it as a compliment
like yeah that is that is a compliment
you know I had a this you know those
like stories were like you think back on
it 10 years later and you're like okay
wait that doesn't add up
I had a friend when we were in high
school so I must've been like 17 or so
she was dating this military guy so like
she thought this was it she said they
got married in a week she did yeah like
she thought at least but no they had
anal within the week right okay I
remember her I remember calling me and
calling me about it she saying I had
anal sex and like I like older friends
she said really
and then I was like you had anal sex and
she was like yeah I was like what was it
was it fun she I was like what happened
and she was like I wouldn't advise it I
mean we did it in the shower and it was
super messy and I didn't like it I'm
like oh okay yo ya gross and now I'm
like I've heard that it's really not
that messy and I'm like it's not happen
yeah [ __ ] all over that's what I did to
tuck it in and it just shot out like on
the wall or some [ __ ] like dude that
like that right when you were talking
about that that popped in my head and I
thought about it I've never hated that
she was [ __ ] and it was a mess and
then she threw up because it was
disgusting and on that note thanks for
thank you to our sponsor today all right
so I'm talking about third love really
quick because third love changed the
game for me with bras oh I used to think
that Victoria cereal was like the only
place that sold bras I don't know why we
all thought that they're really good and
then you find out that you've been
wasting your money on these bras that
don't fit your boobs right and what I
like about third love is they have like
this online quiz where you kind of like
answer different questions about your
boobs if you've shape all the stuff that
you were never asked before you
purchased a pro in the past and things
like tight straps the band that causes
like back fat to show in the back the
gaps in the cups all those things are
not normal things they're not things
that should be part of your bra so I did
not know that before or during a third
love bra and I am so happy to say that
third love is my favorite bra ever I'm
wearing it right now it's like the only
bra that I ever like can fall asleep in
I don't like calling up my bra I think
any time I've ever fallen asleep in a
bra before I woken up and like taking it
off at like 2:00 in the morning yeah and
so it's so comfortable then there she is
she wakes up in another third love bra
yeah so
anyway the third love knows there's a
perfect offer I knew everyone so right
now they are offering our listeners 15%
off your first order go to third level
Ashby TCH now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash b tch for
15% off today get your perfect over the
shoulder Boulder holders oh my god
mine are like pebble holders but it
works and we're back so messy sex Dixon
jeana's nasty-ass sex life she came out
how look I don't give it up often but if
I do you getting it all yeah there's a
type to spit on a bald dudes head dude
have you ever sneezed a dick out before
what it's needs the dick out can you
elaborate these things that's ever
happened to me ever so like me and my
man we're having sex and then you know
like he like I was on birth control cuz
control so he came inside me right and
then like after you think I'm inside you
can't be kind of leave it in there yeah
yeah yeah I like when they pump a little
bit I want every drop yeah like I hit
like so he's still inside me and it's
starting to get a little bit softer
because we're done every sex and also
the sneeze comes out when you sum oh yes
you can try busting out laughing those
by for the firm yet I've laughed it out
once yes yeah yeah funniest like it's so
weird as feeling because he said
something that made me cracked up and
he's still [ __ ] me I'm like stop it
stop I'm trying to laugh but it's like
I'm like stuck between cracking up a
pleasure at the same time and it felt
weird connected to your vag muscles for
some reason that's true maybe like doing
your period and then like you coughed
really badly release really but yeah
yeah eating oh my
on the trampoline on the trampoline like
they're just gonna be able
but the leaks out a little bit oh no oh
it's like I was streaming scary games a
few weeks ago and I screamed so loud I
[ __ ] inked hard I was on my stream I
was like yeah I'm like cuz I told him
was like you guys ever watch Finding
Nemo and this little bittle squid or the
little octopus yeah
so has has like a dick size ever like
mattered to the point of of breaking up
well like what the last episode like I
think I mean I don't know if it was a
size but like because of the dick we
just had to end it
oh yeah do i okay yeah I I was seeing a
guy that was just it was it was [ __ ]
huge and like it got to the point where
like it was like I'm like okay a this is
gross cuz it's I can't your wiener is so
big and it and wieners are just ugly so
magically and then it is bigger you know
and like you know what's ugly r2u like
you know I think that I feel like when
God was just creating like genitals he
was like this looks good this looks good
he's like mmm I don't really care about
this pie right now let's go back down
here like I like genitals are just like
not that attractive but like also it's
just a [ __ ] hurt like imagine like
you're like hang with your man watching
TV and then he's like hey do you want me
to give you a [ __ ] a headache and
like stretch your [ __ ] out and then yes
yes I do know like it wasn't fun but you
know also it was not even from a selfish
standpoint for him like I knew I just I
was not interested in having sex with
him at all not even in the slightest
[ __ ] thing away it has to be about
her it has to be about swagger because
like if you have a dick that hurts and
then also you're not being like
attractive personality wise to me like
you're being a whiny little [ __ ] boy or
you're being like too aggressive in like
like ego II I don't it doesn't sound
like your dick would feel good inside me
but if you're making me laugh and then
and you're like yeah I'm ready to do
this and you're all like nine inches
hard I'm like yeah I really think before
you send a dick picture like like if
you've got a huge wiener okay and you're
sitting there and you'll the end this
picture of your wiener and you're like
let's in the SIS Karl you guys think is
it a Nicki or is it a Bose right it's
not it's not a big joke I'm gonna send
this out you better send your clavicle
to Bose I mean you you really gotta
think about that and like there's this
annoying cockiness or some guys that
like have big wieners and they're like
you see how I'm like a child I'm like a
weiner is like guys that have big
wieners that like want to send it
because they're being bragging about it
that's not the type of guy I would ever
play exact so like the guys that is
personality is a small yeah sure you
might have a big dick but because you're
trying to flaunt it out it's a dudes
that I've had sex with that had big
dicks I had no idea they were packing
that book yeah like yeah it's nice and
cool and funny and I liked them and then
like whoa what is surprise yeah what a
lovely surprise and I know that he's
proud of it too but he ever like just
randomly send dick yeah or talk about it
he really keeps to himself which makes
it so much hotter it does yeah I found
out your secret that's all I wouldn't
you send it I'm like oh I didn't need to
know yeah now I'm kind of like oh you're
like like bragging about it I don't know
what the female equivalent of that would
be like a girl that knows she's hot
though that's a yes I don't like guys
who know they're hot because there are
some fine guys at the moment I find out
that they know they're hot and like
leaning too hard on that yes and not
enough into like a personality or
developing I wonder what how like a guy
can find out what kind of what type of
girl she is
like you wanna buy bozer and nikki like
big dick or regular whatever Wow look is
it away question how would the guy know
communication man likes to dominate I
don't know maybe it's something to do
with that no I'm not necessarily like I
mean I told my boy all the time I'm like
dude if you hit another quarter inch I
would be you would be back on tender
I would be going on oh really yeah you
just barely missed the mark yeah because
this [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts you know and
actually that's one thing you can look
out what's her stature like you know and
she taller is she shorter if she's five
feet tall and you're like oh [ __ ] 10
inches for you baby like I mean that
could surprise you someone yeah the same
reason like hell sighs sighs dicks women
have different size vagina it's true
yeah one of my best friends she looks
like a child and her like she's like
four foot ten or something like that
taking a step husband he's like six foot
two and she likes it look at Shaq I know
Nikki are you an adrenaline junkie uh no
no your I like I like roller coasters
you like a lot of exciting but I don't
like feeling like I'm gonna die okay all
right
do you like pain at all I like
humiliation like in fantasies like I
like like like how Gina likes it so of
like the the like the being completely
dominated so like quit humiliation like
yeah like where they degrade you like
where like like what point in
humiliation like you know like dirty
talk like like don't make me dog [ __ ]
yeah yeah emotionally abuse okay yeah I
want to be treated like a dumb bimbo
yeah I don't know I have a jolly asian
fetish I know we got three out of like
if I'm a submissive or a dominating kind
of person because like I don't know like
it to go too far yeah I guess so I don't
know I guess like I'm in an in-betweener
I'm not that fun but sometimes like fun
I tend to be more dominating though okay
and I think because the guide tends to
be more submissive not like
intentionally it's like I don't know if
there's like one of those cute Dom's it
comes in and it was like take my [ __ ]
shoes off oh leather straps are pink and
food I
Tiff's being like a good Dom like I
could totally see that [ __ ] yeah I mean
most of the time I tend to find myself
on top I don't know no I'm writing you
know I see like TIFF TIFF comes home and
she's like did you work out today why
not are you going later
keep your body want to eat like I see it
like short leash it's like it's a deep
it just it's in there how about um
weird-shaped dicks like nothing doesn't
necessarily like length or curved ones
oh wait I'm just sorry we're talking
about this in two seconds after the sad
break I got my Buffy y'all I finally got
it they tried to take it from me it is
mine now I especially recommend it for
especially bristles if you don't like
birth control or something and you got
night sweats no more night sweats you
know when your man comes over and he's
like wow I really like her but she's
really sweaty you don't have to worry
about that anymore cruelty free made of
eucalyptus so I'm gonna take it from you
beautiful we wanted it I mean it was
sitting over there and then somebody
moved it so I don't know why look
because you listen to our podcast we are
giving you $20 off of your Buffy
comforter all you got to do is go to a
Buffy CO and enter the code b tch
that's Buffy dot CE o and enter b tch do
you want to stop sweating it's you
allergenic too so if y'all are allergic
to down comforters first of all you know
how they make those things and you know
I'm one of those people that like I love
to have like a big like comfy heavy
blanket but then then I stick a foot out
oh yeah yeah and you know it like you
got to stick the foot out just the right
amount so it's the right temperature you
know look give me oh not to worry about
that with Buffy go get your bug in the
bowl Buffy CO and then into the code be
PT ACH 20 bucks off b tch
and we're back okay how about let's talk
about these odd shape ticks and also
girth with like how about that that's
something to consider maybe you have a
shorter dick but it's
girthy I sometimes think that that's
more important while we explore the
I still want to find out what is the
defendant I want to answer the question
because it's such a good question I want
to figure out what is the definitive
difference between you and me and how
people can tell are they a nikkie or are
their bows before they send off that
Weiner pic right before they get a
parent oh I know psychological issues I
was trying to dive into I would say
because you said that you loved the rush
of like arguing and stuff like that and
like I'm not like that you know like
yeah yeah I'm trying to I liked being
completely 100% a scientific study on
that if you have a big computer computer
the army that's true I'm getting
completely dominated that's no
interesting gene has to do but if you
can dominate me with a small dick that's
that's fine I've just never do it with
dicks
if a guy could dominate me with a small
wiener I would be like I would respect
like yeah I kind of you know like I
think I would enjoy that if a guy had a
big dick and he didn't he did wasn't
confident about it I don't think it's
sex would be enjoyable yeah it really
isn't about solely dick size it's about
definitely personality and because like
I had this one guy once that he was
definitely one of the growers and so
when like when he was not growing like
it was just like you know in the
beginning of it he had such low
confidence and I'm like dude you're good
when it's hard like just wait til it
gets there like chill out like yeah I've
seen some guys who like don't look at me
soft and like shut the [ __ ] up like oh
don't let me have no makeup on shut up
[ __ ] I know what's underneath that no
it's gonna happen yet first of all
you're my and I'll look at you whenever
the things that we just can't we can't
give you the question to ask like you
know like when you're doing your length
let's do 25 questions like you slide
that one question and it figure out if
she likes big dicks or not I like the
communication I like when people are
super open like so do you NC and like
all right look I like to get choked a
[ __ ] out
I will let you know I think the one
thing that I don't know how to work with
and I have like probably like zero
experience in is uncircumcised dicks I
have no idea how to work with those do
you pull it back no it does no no okay
when it gets hard it just it's or like
back and it's like a normal day or that
mean like normal but like a it's like a
same day looks the same as an
uncircumcised out the skin you know like
this upon them go over them you know
like giving a hand job to an
uncircumcised dick and she's like you
don't really well for the penises that
I've been that I've been with that are
not circumcised didn't need like a
lubricating there yeah it's like good to
go nature's Lube and this that's pretty
cool but that's still the thing it's
like it's like it's like you were meant
to have that foreskin liquid is emitting
from the hood but causes lubrication I
don't like urethra hole that they
secrete yeah I know the pre-cum and then
it gets like into the hood as you're
rubbing it yeah she learned something
that just deconstructed what I thought
an uncircumcised wiener looked like have
you never been with one I don't think
I'm not experiencing that at all I've no
idea what how it works yeah it's just
like it just when it gets hard
the foreskin falls back and it's like
it's like a circumcised oh you know what
though it is slightly more it's just
it's interesting when you get an
uncircumcised dick that's like extra
skin long sleeve like pulling it back
[Laughter]
though we're talking about this actually
because like you know I don't want
anyone out there to feel like their
dicks weird cuz dicks are like Oh what
you got like I uh I've been with all
kinds of dick shapes and I
all about the person that's owning the
dick yeah yeah like I one of the one
dick that my first the guy I lost my
virginity to
he had a curved dick and so I thought
that all dicks were curved along Oh
interesting
yeah I thought like it was curved up
like this and so like wow that
originally optimal yeah yeah so certain
oh yeah that's like the yeah true I
thought I completely liked like certain
positions and then like when I was with
a guy that didn't have a curved dick I
was like all that position doesn't work
as well and I had a boyfriend that had a
that his dick curved to the left but
yeah we didn't have sex like I the most
we ever did like I gave him a hand job
and it was just like whoa this is weird
turning a curve slightly down like I
think it's called Peyronie's or
something like that oh there's a name
right now yeah real it curves slightly
down oh yeah but it it like feels good
do you guys have even labias minora yes
what's that the inside have you ever
seen that there's like a an image that
floated around the internet and it's
like a vagina chart and there's like 20
different picture uh-huh late you have
you ever I saw in my late 20s and I had
no idea for that many different pagina
showing Steve I was like what the [ __ ]
there's other kinds of a job he was like
yeah like I've been with these any like
so this other circle I immediately
looked at the one that looked like mine
and I was like oh the other one like
guys would message me like are you an ad
or an Audi and I'm looking at my belly
button I'm like I don't know what it's
just when you're so used to seeing one
kind because I didn't really watch like
a lot of porn like at least the porn
that I had seen they all had the same
like kind of vagina so like I had just
didn't know and you know it's a drip at
different kinds I was like wow that's my
vagina changed after having Isaac and he
didn't even go out that way
well yeah like had a c-section and so
I'm like what the [ __ ]
you weren't even used like what happened
but it did change oh yeah like you're
just used to making weight of the
pregnancy like maybe I don't know maybe
but it definitely like
do you think do you think it's sorta
like pushing working with like say
what's my boobs are like they got saggy
ER and like sadder and my vagina got
sadder - I'm like what the [ __ ] Wow
crazy man happily ever having kids to be
a Barrett if everything looks [ __ ]
lit yeah yeah it looks pretty lit - yeah
yeah yo yo vaginas look um I was in
there for the group chat no no I was
just like judging outside yeah yeah I
don't know like we have been naked
around each other no I think we forgot
to bring underwear or a wig what do we
forget to bring we forgot to bring
pajamas or something I didn't bring
things to sleep in so at the first night
really all right look [ __ ] I'm we're
just going on to work came into our room
in the morning like I remember you came
in and you were just laying in the bed
next to me I was like yeah guys pretty
much dream in Vegas like day ones like
you titties are out cuz mine are right
now on the table topless but it's
censored and we're like well yours good
but I should be able to see like what
the breasts actually look that's what's
good about talking about this is cause a
lot of people just want to know that
they're normal like everyone wants to
know like am i weird am i normal and a
lot of guys go through this with dicks I
think like is my size big enough for my
normal is it weird shaped or whatever
and girls with like have the same thing
let your vagina isn't bitten boobs and
all kinds of different body parts and
it's a it's about owning it whatever you
got you just have to own it and that's
what's sexy about it shoes just find
your shoe just find your matching vagina
and you're good go Cinderella no that's
why I'm it was interesting because Isaac
once asked me my son my 11 year old son
he asked me like oh because I try to
keep the conversation of sex as open as
possible and
so I try to never let I never want him
to feel uncomfortable to ask me anything
felt one time he asked me like oh I
forgot the way he phrased it but pretty
much the question was like do you only
have sex when you're in married and so I
pretty much told him like you know what
a lot of old-school people think that
you should wait to have sex for the
first time when once you get married but
I don't agree with that and I feel like
you should really find out what works
with you and once you find that then
that's when you marry it but I even I
told my own son like I really don't
believe that you should wait till
marriage because once you're married
like that's it like you can't [ __ ] out
and like you know you have to make it
work
so no you trippin cuz I'd be like you
wait until you get out of this damn
house then you could sleep in go ahead
because I won't have [ __ ] out of that in
my house yeah I can't like when I have a
kid like I don't even know how I'm gonna
discuss like you know like topics about
like sex and like maturity and something
that about all I know for damn sure is I
need to know where you're going you need
to have your cell phone on you at all
times you're not bucking anyway no all
right the conversation since they're
little like really yeah I started
talking to him about like oh you know
you boys have a wee-wee and girls have
this or whatever and then like you based
on the age like you make the
conversation match his age yeah so that
I made sure like because I grew up in a
household that you never talk about sex
like you never do anything like like you
know my mom would cover my eyes whenever
people would be kissing in a movie yeah
and it made me want to know even more
like it made me like really [ __ ]
curious so I was just like listen we got
it just put it on she didn't want to
have to deal with a horny child yeah I
did yeah hiding it made her more horny
yeah exactly I don't know okay question
for you guys so put yourself in mom mode
for a second yeah you have a child if
son okay your son is 14 his girlfriend
wants to come over is that cool the door
oh that's my question is the door oh is
he allowed to shut the door oh yeah yeah
I wasn't allowed to have any boys in my
room at all door opened or closed
nothing but we were able to hang out on
the living room wouldn't you would you
would you say living room would you say
door bedroom shut the door door open
living room room
yeah oh my god I would I am NOT taking
care of a goddamn grandchild [ __ ] no
dude know what I think that's fair
because I the hell y'all gotta do in
your room you get the Xbox in there take
it out lay down on the couch you know
your guys like I'm like listen you just
only have to promise me that you never
get anyone pregnant until you're ready
for our child you don't go to jail and
just don't do anything stupid where
you're risking your life and you're
pretty much like you know you're gonna
die so I'm like just please don't do
those three things in me
yeah please God having kids it's [ __ ]
scary to go through all these talks like
cuz fight I know that if my kid turned
out like anything like me I would be
terrified that [ __ ] like wide open when
it came to sex cuz look I got pregnant
at 17 I was just like get me out of my
house and for some reason I saw like you
know just boyfriend is the way out and
they're like before we move on just a
quick word from one of our sponsors Bo's
y'all know when you walk in the coffee
shop and you see that cute girl on her
laptop with her coffee just typing away
she's not on social media she's on honey
book because she runs a business she's a
freelancer she's got to send out
invoices collect invoices doing mailing
advertisements everything Gina let me
pull your car see I can be that [ __ ]
even though I'm not organized but I can
fake it because honey book kit takes
care of that in one software it does
everything for you in one place gift a
manager and skip the assistant honey
book on your laptop on your phone in
your head we just got a beefy honey book
showing up look like you got your [ __ ]
together
dude we're not kidding this app like the
software because everything to the point
that we started scrolling through we
were like does it do this to do that
does kwikki you're running your business
but it's compatible with QuickBooks
Google suite and MailChimp and for for
our viewers now thank you for listening
to us we are giving you 50% off your
first year a whole a whole year 50 miles
or
productive in that one year 50% off your
year just all you have to do is go to
honey book calm and use the promo code
b-tch for 50% off your first year
again that's honey book calm and use the
promo code b-tch get paid faster and
work smarter with honey book calm promo
code beat ACA shake it to you make it
make it look like you got your [ __ ]
together
do it girl or guy and wow what a great
sponsor thank you for sponsoring us
today we're back Dix
yeah wieners get on them dream that you
had a dick no I've always wanted a dick
for a day though I've had dreams or
multiple dreams where I have a penis and
I'm it's always me in the bathroom and
I'm about to go pee and I'm like holding
it in my hands I'm like well this is
what it feels like to be like to have
one between my legs
yeah and it's always such a trip and I
wake up and I'm like oh thank god I'm
still a girl like you would do if you
had one I would Jack I want to know what
it feels to jack off yeah yeah then I
will do the helicopter thing cuz that
looks really fun yeah wait you know I
feel like we don't have we don't have
like the full spectrum of representation
as far as their sexualities go unless
wait does you like girls at all no oh
yeah Tiff's like like we important okay
I feel like all of us are like basically
straight and then we have Jess that's
like super straight mega strengh like
super straight but like only in the gay
dudes Oh weird okay yeah interesting
yeah I feel like a lot of I've been
having a lot of lesbian dreams lately
but yeah I wake up I was like oh that's
[ __ ] cool but then I never like in to
me I'm just like I'm not gonna go out
and try to get a girl or anything like
I've experimented before but it was just
not for me how did you experiment I had
a threesome oh [ __ ] yeah like with girls
or with a guy and a girl you wanted the
two girls or was it for knows me another
girl and the guy oh my goodness how does
that even had worked so when I was like
18 19 I was going through like my
exploration phase and I was like go-go
dancing and I did a lot of this is when
I was like was a go-go dancing at it's
like these doth clubs or whatever and I
was like with a lot of burners like
people in they're very open I call them
white people like the white people like
all my white friends were super open I
like their hippies and they're super
like sexual you know and it was [ __ ]
cool like we'd walk around like topless
and stuff and we did like a goth fashion
show at this club and there was this
girl there and she was like kind of
drunk and then she was like she was the
sweetest little thing in the world right
she was like smaller than me and she was
kind of drunk she was like it's like now
I hate you and then I was like um like
I'm kind of open cuz I was like all
about exploration and then she was like
um and then she introduced her boyfriend
this is my boyfriend he was like the
sweet thing to you and we're all golf
kids together Oh Mike cuz I grew up as a
goth kid in high school and then I was
like oh cool and then I thought we're
just gonna be like kind of friends and
hang out and I was and this is like I
was in Li just moved to LA for like a
few years so still trying to make
friends here and there from there yeah
from NorCal yeah from Northern
California and then I was gonna hang out
with them and then she kind of like it
was really cute like he left her room
she was like um so I don't know how to
bring this up to you but um so he and I
have been together for about like 10
years or so they're a little bit older
than me but I've always like recently I
kind of realized that I'm kind of a
lesbian more but I still love him so
much cuz we've been in each other's
lives for so long if they still love
each other so much that they were still
together but and he was open to letting
her fulfill what she wanted and what she
needed so I was like oh cool um and then
she was like and I was wondering like
maybe like do you think I can kiss you
and I'm like yeah okay and he wasn't in
the room he wasn't in the room and then
I was like is this okay with him because
I wanted to be really respectful she's
like yeah it's super okay cuz you know
we're trying to look for like a third
person and I was like oh yeah all right
cool and then so um I wonder if you
would have been that cool and like open
if she wanted to [ __ ] another guy yeah I
wonder - yeah so he came back in the
room and she's like do you think we can
do it in front of him like just make out
in front that's fine and then so they
proposed like it was really sweet like
they were very it wasn't like weird or
like hey you know yeah hey so um do you
think that we can you know add you as a
third to our relationship like we've
always wanted to try like
the girl in our relationship and I was
like yeah that's really sweet that
you're letting her do that you know so
the next time I saw her we went to go
watch a movie it was it was I remember
it was 30 days of night it was a dope
vampire movie because we were so [ __ ]
goth and and you know we were sitting in
the theater and then this is like my
first time ever experiencing this I was
like so you know what are the boundaries
I want to ask you like is what's
off-limits what's okay like do you mind
if he and I have sex it's just you and
me or like and I really want to
understand what she wanted was okay she
was like thank you so much for for
asking you know like we've tried other
people in the past and they were kind of
rude like they didn't understand the
boundaries and it didn't work that out
so she's like thank you so much for
asking so later on that night we did
have sex like it was it was really for
me it wasn't like oh nasty ball balls
like this is actually kind of be like
she like ate you out or yeah but we were
super clean about it they had this
really interesting process where they
put saran wrap like whoa you just ran
her up and laid over her [ __ ] and then
like yeah and that's how I would you
know go down and we would never exchange
fluids
oh we're clean oh through the saran wrap
yeah well I'm so like or like if he had
his fingers in me he would go wash his
hands first and then switch over hurt
like oh wow wow you're really sweet you
have sex with him yeah and she was like
totally okay with that oh my go this is
kind of cool but for me it was more like
it wasn't like dirty nasty [ __ ] yeah
fantasy it was more like this is
actually really sweet doing this for her
yeah they were like so in love is that
the trade-off that like if she gets to
[ __ ] you then he gets to [ __ ] you is it
like that was looking into it too like
or was it more like like he's focused on
her having a good time uh it was he
loved it but we were I I kind of
understood like we both hadn't
understand it was more for her
so it was like let's get her offers and
make sure she's happy first and then
after it at the end of it all we cuddled
in the same bed I was um he was like
well why don't you get in the middle
because I know she wants to cuddle with
you how cute you know it was like the
cutest thing the world I'm like this
isn't even nasty this is adorable yeah
but yeah that was actually really cool
yeah that's the sweetest sex story yeah
and it's like whole threesome
anyway it was
awesome and then so afterwards like well
what I do it again no not really because
I realized that when it comes to sex I
like all the attention on me you know
like I want what I have and I with you
only and I want you to pay attention to
me only and I want to pay attention you
only not have to worry about two
different people
right which is cool but I'm not saying
that I'm not down for a dude dude girl
situation oh I've always wanted that too
but I would never do it yeah that's like
a I was like when I was single
yeah like would have happened yeah a
long time ago yeah but I would never do
it if I was in a relationship lame yeah
if I saw ste with another like if we
were trying to a threesome and he like
[ __ ] another girl I couldn't handle
that me too possessive for that like I'm
not [ __ ] sharing we're - oh I love at
this point but if it was two people I
didn't care about at all like words know
exactly meant then maybe that would have
been cool and that's what I said to my
you know the guy that I date - it's just
like I like you too much I don't want to
share you yeah I want you to share me
either but if I was single and I was
going down I'm [ __ ] down but the
problem with it is it's really hard to
find two dudes are down so yeah that
sounds stressful for me because you know
I'm thinking about there's a whole
there's two penises
you only need one penis no there's a
mouth and then there's a hole that's
where it gets confusing for me because
like when there are two things these two
things go together now when there's
three now there's multiple pairs now you
have what 16 pops around you know what
it is like that for me and it's very
stressful I like it because I'm stressed
out by normal life and that makes me not
be able to think about anything else
there's too many dicks going on it's
like in normal life I think of 10,000
things so many dicks makes me not think
about anything else exactly of yours
with two dicks would you be down for
them to get [ __ ] going to know
I'm imagining Jeff just come in like
yeah just pulls out like like one of
those sticks and it's like you put that
finger like yeah all right hold that
right there
I think the hot thing about is it's just
like it's like multiple men that want to
make me feel good you know that's just
oh it's not Oh for me it's like I don't
want them to make me feel good I want to
use me oh yeah there's a hoary side of
it yeah my pleasure is irrelevant like
may need to use oh that's where you get
your place yeah but then afterwards like
after all the sex is done I need them to
be really nice and like after like I
can't I can't have you like gentlemen
wait after the sex like after Steve and
I do that in here yeah it's important
you so much you're so cool like you know
yeah it's super important yeah that's
like that's the that's a actually see
anything yeah it's a huge thing in the
fetish community when you have like
super like extreme sex like that
aftercare is a huge thing like you have
to take care of them afterwards I hear
you okay did I hurt you do you need
anything it's like it's like the
sweetest thing yeah it's like none of
that was real like you are you have
worth as a person exactly yeah you're
not a bris because like you actually
want people to treat you like that
exactly you know I wonder if it's a
similar fetish for guys like of course
guys want to have a threesome with two
girls right but I feel like there's a
type of threesome where the two girls
are like everything's just [ __ ] nasty
you know but then what if there is like
a threesome where like the two women are
like just using the guys out here you
know like I feel like some guys would be
like super into that you know if you go
on pornhub lookup reverse gangbang
that's the thing oh my god that that's
interesting so one beer bunch of chicks
yeah I can't do that
yeah I'm not about it yeah and meanwhile
that to me I'm interested like oh I'd
like to see that and then you like oh
yes dude I did ass I caught myself cuz
like while you were listening yours I
had like this most judgmental face I was
like
they'll yuck someone's YUM okay I was
like both straighten your face I know I
was raised Christian like wait a bunch
of girls being in a dude like I don't
know about that and I'm like yeah I
thought Nikki that because I went on her
podcast yeah we talked about for geez I
used to go to swinger parties and it was
me and the guy that I was dating we like
we didn't like sharing each other or
whatever we just liked watching people
and we liked being in a room where
people grow your ism yeah voyeurism so I
liked being watched always having sex
and when you're new to the club they
make you come an hour early and you have
to go through like an orientation like a
safety and like you know what you can't
do what you can't do and the phrase that
they taught us was don't young someone's
young she's actually a schoolteacher wow
that makes perfect sense yeah like
imagine her a kindergarten teacher
saying that it's knowing that she's
going to the BDSM no for me I think um
like I tried thinking about it I'm like
because I'm the type of person that I
want to always try something once like
everything once yeah and but I tried to
think about like the threesome stuff and
I'm like I don't know because yeah I
watch lesbian porn but after I kissed a
girl in high school to me that was like
the most like weirdest like Annette yeah
for me yeah we're always like I I can't
like it's too soft like yeah and some of
the girls in high school they would have
their experimental phases to where they
would be like yeah last night we went to
this house party and I ate that girl out
and I'm like high school because in high
school you're trying to be cool it's
like oh that I did this you know
actually on the contrary like wanna like
not necessarily sad but like on a like
different this perspective like okay you
guys know how like some women might
shoot like might become lesbians after
having some really bad experiences with
men yeah I've been cornered by two
lesbians and like in like in incredibly
traumatizing situations like the first
one being like there is
girl that like my two friends would
always stay at her house and she was
like she was a year older than us and
like they would hang out with her and
she was like popular and kind of cool
but like looked like like short blond
hair you know da da da da
and I wanted to be your friend too so I
went to crash at her house one night she
invited me to stay over she had this big
house her parents were like good parents
with like cookies on the table and stuff
and it was just like a regular sleepover
we were like 15 or so we go to bed and
she tries to make a move on me and I'm
like anything that's when it clicks I'm
like oh this is what my friends were
doing with this girl and I'm like well
she assumed that because I was friends
with that like this was a little
threesome that we were just mucking
having like every night and so she kept
pushing me and pushing me to like do
[ __ ] with me and I'm like no bro I'm
[ __ ] good like I am beyond good and I
had to stay at this girl's house and
then she was pissed at me because I
didn't want to [ __ ] around with her next
day come to school this girl told
everyone that I'd [ __ ] her Wow yeah
like it's no different than a guy doing
that and that was very embarrassing like
upsetting for me like I mean of course
now like if you know if somebody says oh
we [ __ ] you're like we know how to
handle that at our age but at 15 that's
kind of like and devastating it really
is and I was also raised as like a
Christian which I wasn't Christian at
the time but for me it was like you're
telling everyone that I did this
horrible thing that like my mother would
be like so upset about and so that was
very traumatizing for me and because of
that and a few other things I ended up
going to a different school and so I'm
already like I don't like girls like oh
and then a few years later something
similar happened with a girl I worked
with I went to I went to her apartment
with another friend and they were
drinking and I was 20 at the time and
like she was older so she could like get
alcohol and so I went to crash like I
went to her house she lived like I think
like maybe three miles away from me and
so I drove over there after work we
drank like we all have fun or whatever
and I got like super drunk cuz I was
only 20 in she was like oh you can crash
here and even though I had that bad
experience I still was like of a sound
mind enough to not be like oh not every
girl wants to [ __ ] me not every girls
into me and so I slept over at her house
and she's like oh you can sleep in my
bed it's totally cool I'm like alright
great I [ __ ] wake up and she's trying
to do [ __ ] yeah
- and that to me is like the biggest
like no no don't [ __ ] touch me if I'm
sleepy not don't not and like also like
you know there was already a previous
like I'm not gonna do anything and like
I I trust you you know so I wake up and
like I immediately get like a little
traumatized back to this other girl
trying to [ __ ] get record that
exactly I get in my car
wasted and drive home and I'm like never
talk to her again so like for me I've
had I've had predatory women like come
on to me and maybe it's because they
gave off some masculine energy they were
like yeah we can suck and turn her out
and I'm like I'm good you know like no
like no hard feelings or anything but
like no I couldn't do threesomes I'm not
I'm not really like into girls like it's
just you know and it's cuz I had some
unfortunate experiences before and it
just turned me off in general so [ __ ]
either yeah yeah but it's you know it's
no different than like you know when a
guy does absolutely yeah but it's
something I've never talked about
because like in also ten years ago like
not a lot of people were out like now
it's so much more common to be accepted
by LGBTQ people are like you know the
community and like you know everyone's
[ __ ] great the community is great but
for me personally because those
experiences I'm just not into women yeah
you know yeah for me it's just like I
just realized that afterwards like after
that whole the whole experience I was
like yeah it's cool I appreciate
beautiful women like I love beautiful
yeah dude my boy night all the time we
look at girls will be like she's [ __ ]
cute you know like we've got all the
time exactly I'm all about it I love
that and that's I think that's why I
love the community that I grew up with
in my early 20s with all the burners and
the go-go dancers and stuff because
everyone was so open about everything I
saw so many titties and dressing rooms
and stuff and they were all awesome and
they had like orgies and stuff all the
time but it's just like it made me more
comfortable with sex which like I love
that's one of my favorite parts about me
that I'm so comfortable about sex like
if you can you told me I like to eat ass
and he shits in my mouth or whatever I
mean different strokes for different
folks but you know what yeah I'm happy
for you you know because I think
everybody has some kind of fetish and
like they like they're either denying it
or they're suppressing it or whatever
but everybody has some sort of fetish so
let's all like you know not yuck each
other's you I'm gonna let your freak
flag fly yeah this can't win from dick
size to fetishes but
a little taste of what's to come on the
hey [ __ ] podcast so if you liked what
you heard you should give us a 5 star
rating on iTunes or greatest thumbs up
on YouTube subscribe and do all that
stuff we got other girls that aren't
here today but they will be on future
episodes so stick around see what's next
also shout-out to Buffy our sponsor and
was there also shout out to Buffy our
sponsor a third love and honey book we
love you all so much for sponsoring us
thank you thank you for 15% off of your
perfect bra at third love go to third
love comm / b tch for 50% off your first
year of honey book go to honey book calm
and use the promo code b tch and get
paid get paid faster and work smarter
with promo code b tch and also lastly
but not leastly for $20 off your Buffy
comforter Bo's visit Buffy dot CEO and
enter b tch
thank you dicks and your and your badge
is in all your body part and remember
don't you someone's young yeah baby